[Music]
from uber drivers to house cleaners to
hosts for airbnb millions of americans
are part of what's known as the gig or
sharing economy instead of a traditional
full-time job they piece together an
income where and when they can that also
means they're not getting the benefits
or security that many full-time workers
traditionally receive and on this labor
day weekend some say that needs to
change here to talk about it with us is
vera gibbons a finance expert and
founder and editor-in-chief of the
website non-political news vera good
morning good morning how fast is this
gig economy growing it's very it's
growing very quickly so about 34 of the
work for us now
gay workers and expected to grow to 40
by 2020. i mean a lot of it has to do
with what happened after the recession
the employers didn't want the financial
commitment of bringing people on full
time it's an expensive proposition but
you also have on the other side people
who want the gigs so they're there by
choice not because they have to be given
flexibility yeah i mentioned the airbnb
and the ubers people know those what are
some of the other areas that were well
though the rise in the on-demand workers
is obviously fueled by the airbnb the
lifts the task rabbits but i think
what's happening now responsible for the
rise is the technology so you're seeing
it across a wide range of digital
platforms car sharing online staffing
peer-to-peer finance and there's really
no end in sight the work that involves a
single task
is out there so you're seeing it really
all over the place so if the if there
are no medical and or insurance benefits
what's the allure well you touched on
anthony it's the flexibility right so
everybody likes the fact that you can
have your own hours you can work as much
as you want to as little as you want to
you can work mornings you can work
evenings so that's the main draw people
for the most part are happy in these
situations they like the money they say
it's fun they like the social aspect but
it is the flexibility that's key
flexibility is great but you do need
some of those other things that you
mentioned so who are the people that are
most attracted to these jobs well the
millennials primarily i mean they're the
ones who are big in this game but we are
also seeing a growing percentage of the
pre-retirees and the retirees get in too
so about 10 percent of pre-retire
pre-retiree households and 11 percent of
retiree households are actually in the
game too and they like it for those same
reasons but again it is the social
aspect primarily for them they like
making a little extra money and they
don't have the financial independent
kids at home yeah but some people say
this this new economy is kind of like
the wild west that there's no real
regulation here i mean
that's the problem so are we going to
get there do you think some some are
calling for oversight complete
regulation that you see in the
traditional labor market there's talk
about portable benefits for example lots
of different balls in the air i don't
know we'll actually
get there right away i think the
regulatory changes that are being talked
about sort of a long way to go we're
sort of in unchartered territory here
but i think at some point
the employees are going to have to
change their staffing strategies because
they've got to stay competitive so
i don't know what'll happen do you think
these types of jobs will eventually just
take over and replace the traditional
job well if you look at the gig economy
as a whole it is growing faster than the
traditional payroll employment and in
some sectors and in some areas it is
superseding it is the primary mode of
employment so it'd be interesting to see
how this actually shakes out
particularly when you have these new
technologies coming on board you've got
this the the self-driving cars you've
got all these different technologies um
drones
artificial intelligence so what will the
gig economy look like down the line
nobody knows 10 years from now it's
going to be very different
it's just not going away though i think
it's just going to explode yeah 10 years
ago we didn't have uber exactly all
right eric gibbons thanks so much for
being with us this morning